bijoux les huit jours qui m'ont mis en
recrutement des filles pas vu la queue
du c'est bien ici le bureau de
recrutement des filles oui on l'a eue
c'est bien ici le recrutement des filles
we all 1 200 g de playboy
aujourd'hui l'agent l'inspecteur bon y'a
du boulot
alors tout d'abord fera pour la
reconnaître les grades 1 alors moi je
suis pas un inspecteur je suis pas
embrigader tu as a à un alcoolique
bon je suis un os à abruti bon y'a
toujours
je suis à dieu dans voilà et pour
reconnaître les grades c'est très facile
plus nez rouge plus adepte élevé
l'adjudant gérard carrier se fait
d'inquiétudes un carrier ya du boulot
on a mis des siècles à faire entrer les
filles à l'armée c'est pas pareil tout
l'humour 1 alors d'abord j'aimerais
savoir pourquoi voulait rentrer alors
moi j'ai bien avant j'étais bonne à tout
faire
oui puis je me suis rendu compte que
j'étais bonne à rien alors à force me
suis dit pourquoi ma fille tu reste plus
qu'une chose c'est l'armée et puis je me
suis ce sera un travail quoi voir si
vous cherchez du travail à l'armée et à
erreur
parce que nous aussi nous sommes touchés
par la crise depuis la guerre d'algérie
en hochant maintenant révolue on
travaille un petit peu en intérim ou le
tchad un coup le divan mais c'est pas ça
on travaille c'est pas une bonne
motivation et ben j'en ai une autre
c'est chez moi c'est un peu hérédité
envoyer ses pères en fils parce que mon
père était dans la miss oui ça ça ira ça
bon mois ci à cause d'un chagrin d'amour
ah bon ça se voit pas ne serait-ce que
ça s'est passé il ya trois ans et
comment ça s'est passé à l'aller bafa là
c'est que j'ai quitté mon mari pour mon
amour j'ai vécu avec mon allemand très
très heureuse pendant trois heures et
makengo
et puis je suis pas ce qui s'est passé
hier soir tout d'un coup ça m'a pris ça
m'est devenu un chagrin d'amour a dit on
alors j'ai décidé de rentrer dans les
ordres mais c'était complet oui je sais
pas ce qu'il se passe mais je peux vous
dire qu'ils se bousculent le goupillon
il paraît que les jo des problèmes de
foie en ce moment à bath et surestiment
ans la durée un peu par landreau
du boulot ça voulait dire exactement
couvrir pour apprendre les quads bon et
puis d'abord je veux savoir dans quelle
arme vous voulez servir ça c'est un peu
moi enfin on m'a parlé d'un engin qui
tire 1500 cola minutes
super j'aimerais bien le voir parce
qu'au début j'ai pensé aller dans génie
mais faire la lessive tous les jours ce
matin et sport ya du boulot
alors si on vous le dira l'instrument
qui tient 1500 coup les murs et une
mitraillette un simple client 1 d'abord
ce geste vous savez ce que c'est qu'une
mitraillette qu une petite mitre bon
mitraillette mais 3000 une moitié de
triet ya du boulot un bon vous donc
énorme où les servir déjà quelle arme je
voudrais aller oui donc là on voulait
aller faut y aller du d'un ba oui de
temps parce que nous avons beaucoup de
pleurs et puis c'est moins confortable à
la du boulot bon d'abord ce que vous
savez les y ont appelés pour l'école
d'officiers légion sur l'a2 pas si c'est
pour faire la chaîne remercie
vous voyez mouvement vous nous voyez
chanter tiens voilà du boudin ya du
boulot parce que l'uniforme ça se fait
pas comme ça l'uniforme ça se mérite
ne serait ce que pour les avantages
qu'ils procurent pourquoi par exemple
comme avantage
demi-tarif dans le métro au cinéma dans
les trains et puis si vous avez la
chance de travail itt vous avez une
place entière dans le métro ayant ainsi
un truc mais ça ça vous concerne très
peu c'est pour draguer moi c'est mieux
mais ça c'est pas à ce propos dragueuse
domine ça vous irait moi je suis bien
dans la glace et les mines sont pas
insensibles
alors là il ya aucun risque à rouler
fleuret vous sautent dessus
eh ben ça me changera de roger petit
comme un sablier les dragueurs 2008 un
combat s'habiller quand le monde rangers
failli mais l'iran tierces à talon
aiguille et porte jarretelles kaki
voyons et puis les bandes molletières
réveille aussi du boulot dit à l'heure
mais là on peut mourir ça oui ça il ya
des gens seraient allés au baroud
le baroud vous aimez sympa et ça roule
plein quand j'ai vu tout de suite pour
cette rentrée là les fesses comme un
char d'assaut les cinquante et un nul
je savais que j'étais faite pour cela et
alors moi moi je veux être la première
seule date inconnue a fait mon ton beau
avec son temps que mon nom en gros comme
ça
ouais ouais ouais c'est ça qui serait
une victoire du féminisme
ils rentrent sains des monuments morte
ouais